I'm Cisco whitey Anton and Jonna pasta
Poulos they have been mostly so far
engaged in understanding our problem
formulations and providing feedback and
over time we will also hope to have some
implementations but this talk currently
is more on the theory side so I will
give one brief one slide just motivating
the problem and why we are interested in
general streaming setup is shown in the
figure here typically a source stream
consists of a bunch of information
packets each packet has a certain
deadline with which it should be played
back if a packet is delayed then it
causes interruptions in the playback
streams and various other artifacts as
well now different streaming
applications have very different
characteristics in terms of the required
bitrate the packet sizes the delays the
packet loss rate and so on
when we consider real-time applications
such as video conferencing and
interactive gaming the typical delays
are quite small typically 100
milliseconds and less and so when we do
coding for such applications we have to
explicitly account for the streaming
nature of the source and deadlines as we
cannot have large buffers and so on so
that abstraction that I will discuss in
this talk is the following we have
basically at each time a source packet
coming in to the encoder so a time I the
source packet si comes in will assume it
consists of K symbols over some field FQ
the encoder must operate in a causal
fashion so at time I generates a channel
packet X I which can depend on all the
source packets up to an including time I
but not on the future ones this which is
a causal encoder the channel packet will
consist of n symbols so the rate of the
code is K by n this channel packets are
transmitted one at a time over a channel
we will focus on erasure channels so
either the output is an erasure or equal
to the channel input X I so Y is either
equal to X I or equals an erasure this
memory finite in the encoding arisa's we
allow right now for it to be arbitrary
but our constructions will typically use
finite memory codes as we will see but
the converse is can be proved will be
proven in this generality the receiver
must reconstruct the source packets
again in a sequential fashion with a
fixed delay so here T is the decoding
delay so as 0 must be reconstructed at
time T and so on at time T plus 1 and so
on one after the other so we have this
set up with a causal encoder and a delay
constraint decoder and this will be
referred to as a streaming code in our
talk now the type of channels we are
interested in should it is often
observed in practice that packet losses
are correlated when you have a packet
loss there will be again a packet losses
that occur in bunch and these are
typically modeled using models such as
the Gilbert Iliad channel this is a
two-state channel where if the channel
is in the bad state packets are lost
essentially with probability 1 so we see
a bunch of packet losses here in bursts
corresponding to the bad state when the
channel is in good state typically it
behaves like an iid channel with some
small loss probability so we will see a
few isolated losses as shown here and so
ideally we would like to find the best
possible streaming code for a given rate
that minimizes the packet loss rate this
turns out to be a rather difficult
problem in fact I think even computing
the loss rate for a given code is quite
challenging because of all the effects
from previous losses will carry over
when the delays are finite so because of
that we will focus on a simplification
and consider what we will call a sliding
window channel model in this model
basically we try to put local
constraints on the type of original
patterns so it is defined as follows if
you take any window of length W the
channel can introduce one of the
following patterns either you see a
burst of length B or up to any ratios in
isolated positions so take any local
window of W consecutive symbols in that
particular window you are allowed to
either have a burst of length B or up to
any ratios in arbitrary positions and
the idea is we want to work with
channels that have both both stand
isolated loss
but it's somehow tractable so we can
prove some results later on we will see
that if he's choosing the parameters in
the right way then codes for this
particular channel will also continue to
perform well over statistical models so
we'll revisit this in the simulations
later on so here is a recap of our
system we have basically a causal
encoder the child of eurasia channel
will be the sliding window channel that
we saw in the previous slide the decoder
is a delay constraint decoder verities
the decoding delay and the rate of the
code is K by n we say our ATR is
achievable over such a channel if there
exists a sequence of encoding and
decoding functions so such that each
source packet can be reconstructed with
a delay of T and over a field size that
can be sufficiently large so we do not
put constraints on the field size and
the supremum of all rates will be the
capacity so this is the quantity we will
be interested in this is the streaming
capacity I should note that this is a
worst case definition we are not putting
any probability distribution over the
channels in the sliding window model our
code should work for all possible
channels in this particular class so no
matter which channel comes up the
decoder should reconstruct each source
packet with a delay of T also we are
allowing for fuel sizes to be
arbitrarily large we are not trying to
put constraints on that although the
coding schemes that we develop will have
will be explicit and we can bound the
field size is required in the course so
I can now if the understa right any
questions I will move on to the results
we needed to be sufficiently large
because we are using some sort of
Constituent codes like strongly MDS
codes that require a certain amount of
field size so I don't want to make it
binary or make it but I can give bounds
on the size of the field size the best
course of we have actually have field
size which is like t cube we have
various constructions and field size
so the main result which appeared in
this paper which should just appear soon
in 90 transactions is upper and lower
bounds on the streaming capacity which
are essentially within one unit of the
decoding delay so our upper bound says
that any feasible streaming code over
such a channel should satisfy the
following upper bound our over 1 minus R
times P plus n should be less than the
minimum of W and T plus 1 and the lower
bound says that there exists a
particular class of quotes that can
achieve a rate R that satisfies the
following lower bound this is very
similar to the upper bound except that
we have minus 1 on the right hand side
so we are within one unit of the optimum
delay in this case
so a couple of other remarks if I fix
the rate of the code if I fix R then
this says that we cannot arbitrary large
be and and simultaneously if I have a
code that corrects long bursts it cannot
correct many isolated erasers and vice
versa
they are governed by this particular
trade-off and later on we will see that
the properties required for both
duration correction and correction of
Arbit isolate arbitrary rangers are
different one comes from span the other
comes from distance and there is an
inherent trade-off between these
quantities so that is manifested in this
bout also the right hand side is the
minimum of W and T plus 1 so n is
basically the number of isolated ear H
take a window of length W in this window
you can either have a burst of length B
or you can have up to any ratios in
arbitrary positions like I can do an
example so it says that if you can
correct a burst of length B then that's
the maximum value is this quantity or
you can correct up to any rangers in
that window if you can correct a long
burst you won't be able to correct too
many isolated erasers based on this
trade-off and converse dog if you
correct many isolated ratios you cannot
correct long bursts and later on I will
explain why this trade-off comes from a
structural point of view like Y by
certain structure is required for burst
error correction and isolated erasers
zero right right so so B has to be at
least greater than or equal to n I
should because a bursty nature is a
particular kind of IRA's your pattern
and it's arbitrary right we allow for
our bits of worst case definition so
take any window of length W you can have
up to any ratios or a burst of length B
in the set up a ball station is a
particular kind of an erasure pattern
you can have a longer burst but up to
any racers maybe I should just do an
example I put it as a back off both
otherwise the capacity is zero that's in
the theorem so let me just do a quick so
here is an example of N equals to B
equals 3 and W equals 6 so you can if
you take any window of length W you can
have 2 isolated erasers or a burst of
length 3 and so on if I take any
consecutive window of length 6
I can either see a burst of length 6 or
3 or 2 erasers and arbitrary positions
in this example and any suffer any
erasure pattern that satisfies this
constraint would be in the class of my
sliding window erasure channel
and so W has to be greater than B plus
one which is given here otherwise the
capacity will be zero so I what I will
to do is mostly focus on how this lower
bound was achieved and why the obvious
construction does not work so we'll
start with the with a simple code
construction which is basically a
systematic code at each time the channel
packet X I will consist of the incoming
source packet and n minus K parity check
symbols okay so let's say we have a
structure like this each parity check is
obtained by taking some linear
combinations of the past M source
symbols in this particular code and
basically the way we generally think
about parity checks is each it will give
us some sort of an equation involving
the source symbols so if I have like
four packets that are erased as 0 s 1 s
2 s 3 then I will basically wait until I
have enough number of parity checks so
that I can essentially invert the system
of equations and recover the missing
source packets so here if it's a rate
1/2 code and if I have four missing
source packets I have to wait till time
7 until I recover all the source packets
and all of them will be recovered
simultaneously so in a sense we want the
system of equations to be full rank and
once it is then we can recover
everything that is missing so in this
particle physicists which have this
dimensions have selected at random we
get random linear codes where such full
rank property is satisfied with high
probability
there are also deterministic
constructions such as strongly MDS codes
which are convolutional counterparts of
MDS codes block MDS codes that guarantee
this full ranked condition in a certain
window of interest but the main point
here is that such code when we think of
parities as providing equations
involving source symbols everything has
to be recovered simultaneously and what
we want our constructions where the
source packets must be recovered
sequentially as 0 should be recovered
before s1 before s2 so somehow the
construction should discriminate the
source packets based on their dead
so I will explain to you how such a
construction can be done in a simple
example and then I will sketch the
general construction and the example we
have is that of a bolster raiser channel
so imagine the channel only introduces
an erasure burst say of length 4 and so
the decoding delays 8 in this case the
optimum rate can be shown to be 2 over 3
and I will explain how we can construct
a code with this rate so what we will do
is we will combine two simple codes one
of which is the kind of an erasure code
we saw on the previous slide and the
other is a repetition code in a certain
way such that we will achieve a code of
the optimum rate so the code on the top
is a rate 1/2 erasure code so if we have
a burst of length 4 then we will have to
wait till we get the 4 parity checks a
by x 7 and we will be able to recover
all the four source packets the code
below is just a repetition code a copy
of each source packet is simply repeated
with a delay of T so T is 8 in this case
so u 0 is appended to u8 the incoming
source packet at time 8 and together
they are sent at timing this is also
rate half code but we are not doing any
combination across the source packets
just a simple repetition okay so let's
put these two codes on top of one
another so what we have done is you have
taken each source packet to split it
into u and V sub packets of the same
size we apply the erasure code to the V
stream of rate 1/2 and then we apply the
repetition code to the u stream so
overall code also has a rate of 1/2
because we are just concatenating to
rate 1/2 course and again here the
decoding will be done separately the V
stream will be decoded using the P
symbols and the u stream with the last
layer so there's nothing done so far but
the key point is that the parameters
were selected so such that you can
combine the two layers of parity checks
the P and the u symbols in the last two
layers it turns out that they are not
interfering with one another in the
recovery process so for this particular
construction we have to source packets
and one parity check this has a rate of
2/3 and if you have a burst of length 4
then from time 4 to 7 we can reconstruct
all
the V packets because they use that
combined with them are before times zero
so they are not erased they can be
subtracted out so the P symbols are
sufficient or to recover the V's at
times seven months we have recovered the
V symbols we can cancel the piece from
tiny 8 onwards they can be just computed
and concerned so all the you symbols can
be recovered sequentially from time 8 9
the source packet is basically u comma V
so at time 8 we have recovered as 0
which consists of u 0 and V 0 at time 9
we have s 1 which consists of u 1 and V
1 and so on in a sequential fashion and
this turns out to basically give the
optimum rate this particular idea can be
generalized actually to any arbitrary
burst length and delay by the basic
steps are sketched here but the
high-level idea is you should take a
source packet split it into two sub
packets of the right dimensions which
are shown here apply a repetition code
to one group a standard erasure code to
the other group combine the resulting
parity checks and append it to the
incoming source packets and if the
parameters are selected in the right way
we will get a rate of T over T plus B so
what happens is when you have a burst of
length 4 here you 0 and V 0 are both
lost right u 0 is protected by this
repetition code here and so if if this
was lost and if P it cannot be computed
this parity check cannot be used but it
so happens that when we have a burst of
length 4 we will be using P 4 2 P 7
to reconstruct the V symbols and at that
time we can subtract out u the u parts
which happens before the bursts this is
what I meant by the fact that the two
layers you have designed the parameters
so that they can be cancelled out right
in particular p8 which could be a
function of V 0 to V 3 can be computed
and canceled out
so I'm going to extend this beyond
bursty nature channels it turns out that
the extension turned out to be
surprisingly simple when we have to
correct both both generators and
isolated losses what we realized is that
the main bottleneck when we have
isolated losses is the repetition coal
u0 is repeated again at time 8 u 1 at
time 9 so if i have a duration at time 0
and 8 for example u0 cannot be recovered
so that the bottleneck when we have
isolated erasers in the sliding window
model turns out to be the repetition
code and what turned out to be the right
thing to do at least as far as the lower
bound was concerned was to apply an
extra layer code to the u symbols which
is this last layer of packets which are
obtained by applying an erasure code to
the used symbols as shown here and
appending it to the previous bursty
racial code so we start with the bursty
erasure code and then when we have to
correct isolated erasers as well
depending on the value of n we have an
extra layer of parity checks as shown
here and by suitably selecting the value
of K we will be able to in fact achieve
the lower bound that was stated in the
theorem so has a nice architecture in
the sense that we start with a worse
serial code and then as we start seeing
more and more isolated erasure we can
vary the size of the last layer to
correct for these erasers so now let me
slightly change the direction and talk
about some structural properties of
these codes what is so different in
streaming than the original
constructions so I gave a specific code
construction and I achieve the lower
bound but let me talk about the problem
slightly more abstractly these are all
convolutional codes as was pointed out
yesterday in my short presentation every
time we take K symbols as input and
generate and symbols as output
so typically convolutional codes are
most naturally thought of in terms of
trellis diagrams so the blue circles
here are the states of the trellis and
the paths through the trellis represent
the different code words classically we
try to design convolutional codes for
maximum free distance but when we have
such delay constraints it turns out that
we should look at more
distance matrix so here is a definition
of the column distance of a
convolutional code which is actually
known in the literature professor
Costello has done a lot of work on this
in the context of sequential decoding
but it turns out to be also relevant in
the context of streaming problem so the
convolutional the column distance is
defined in the following way we
basically take the interval from time 0
to T so this is the resulting generator
matrix of the convolutional code in this
interval which is basically the
truncated generator matrix it has the
block puppet structure and we look at
all possible code words that are induced
by all input sequence is simple input
sequences whereas 0 is nonzero and then
we find the code word with minimum
Hamming weight in this set so what this
is really doing is basically if you go
back to the trellis diagram it is
looking for all code words that diverge
from the all 0 state at time 0 then
looking at the code words in the
interval 0 to T and finding the
particular code word with minimum weight
that is the column distance of the code
so the key is you have to allow for the
first symbol to be nonzero for this
definition to work another metric we
need is the column span the column span
of a code is defined in a very similar
way as the column distance except you
look at the span length so the interval
from the first nonzero symbol to the
last nonzero symbol and find the code
with the smallest span that is the
column span and these properties can be
shown to be directly related to the
error correction or over the sliding
window model we can show that a code is
feasible over such a channel if and only
if the column distance is greater than n
plus 1 and the column span is greater
than or equal to B plus 1 so our main
result can be translated into a trade
off between the achievable column
distance and column span you can show
that for any convolutional code the
column distance and column span must
satisfy this particular upper bound we
cannot have a code with large column
distance and column spans simultaneously
and conversely our proposed construction
achieves this particular lower bound and
so in a sense what we are doing is
finding codes that simultaneously have
good call
distance and column span and so we gave
a name to this course we call their
Midas codes for maximum distance and
span codes or as for so seem to make
sense in this framework but we are not
aware of such a result from the
classical convolutional coding
literature so it might be interesting to
see whether there are alternative proofs
that do not appeal to our operational
definition of the streaming setter so
let me now briefly go back and talk
about statistical models and show some
simulation results and then wrap up so
we will go back to the Gilbert Iliad
channel which has two states when the
channel is in the bad state it
introduces both losses are typically the
burst losses will have an exponential
distribution for the Gilbert in your
channel depending on the value of beta
here which is taken to be 0.5 that
determines the mean burst length alpha
determines the gap between successive
bursts it's the probability for going
from good state to bad state we fixed
the delay it to be 12 and the rate of
the code to be about half and we when
the channel is in the good state we like
the probability of loss be epsilon so in
the good state the loss is not 0 it is
in the Gilbert model it is zero but in
the Gilbert alert we allow for some loss
probability and here is a simulation
result we have we we vary epsilon on the
x axis the loss probability in the good
state from 10 to the minus 3 to 10 to
the minus 2 from the y axis we plot the
residual loss for different course the
blue line here is just the uncoated loss
rate as we increase epsilon the loss
probability will increase and that is
basically shown here without any coding
and there are three plots here
corresponding to three different codes
of the same rate when the delay is 12
the [ __ ] is the kind of horizontal line
here the black line corresponds to a
classical erasure code that achieves N
equals B equals 6
so this code can correct up to 6
isolated erasers or a burst of length 6
in this window of length T and so this
code is very insensitive as we increase
epsilon as we start adding random losses
because of the large value of n it can
basically clean up everything but
because B is small it basically suffers
from longer bursts
and that is seen in this part of the
code the red line here corresponds to a
code that can only correct burst erasers
this is corresponds to N equals 1 and B
equals 11 and so as we start increasing
Epsilon the performance such deteriorate
rather quickly although an epsilon is
very small when we essentially only have
worse losses the code performs well and
our particular code accuses N equals 2
and VB equals 9 in the family we have
achieves a relatively long bursts and
also can be robust up to two erasers and
has the best performance in this regime
if we go to like more sophisticated
order models such as the freshman
channel then it turns out that the burst
losses are hyper geometric distributions
in this case we can actually get a lot
better performance gains than the
classical course and the Gilbert Ilha
channel because of the exponential
distribution it actually some somewhat
favours classical codes but if you have
longer bursts then we can get up to an
order of magnitude gain over the
baseline schemes which is what is shown
in this simulation I only have a couple
of minutes so I will just quickly go a
wrap up we have several other extensions
so we have a multicast extension the
idea is when the channel is good we
should decode with a smaller delay but
the channel is bad we should decode with
a longer delay and the problem from a
coding theory point of view corresponds
to finding quotes with good column span
profile not just looking at one value of
column span for a given delay but as you
increase delay look at the whole profile
and this turns out to be rather
intricate and we have some results in
this particular paper we have also
looked at several other extensions such
as mismatched streaming course when the
source arrival and the channel
transmission rates are not the same we
have one source packet every M channel
uses then how can the construction be
generalized we have partial recovery
codes that do not recover all the source
packets in the stream but a subset of
them and they are useful in certain
cases which was in this paper we have
dealt with multiple erasure boards
multiple links and multiple source
streams with different decoding delays
so I will give a couple of related words
to this problem that there hasn't been a
lot of work but the problem of streaming
over both serial channels was originally
looked at mark
and sunburn and actually I should give a
lot of credit to this paper where the
originally formulated the problem
unfortunately the construction was
somewhat combinatorial in nature and it
was not obvious how to generalize it to
this various other extensions the
layered coding approach that I presented
here actually has a nice benefit that it
could be generalized in many of the
setups that I discussed there is also
related for a more recent related work
by Liang and ho-young Qureshi and Howe
where the authors have looked at similar
streaming problems but the connections
are closer to network coding rather than
the kind of bursts and isolated erasers
that we have been considering so that
pretty much concludes my talk I
discussed the problem of real-time
communications over channels with bursts
and isolated erasers we introduced a new
class of Cole called Midas codes that
are based on a layered coding approach
and achieve optimal trade-off between
column distance and column span or a
near optimal trade-off I should say in
terms of future work we still have there
are still certain channels that are
quite challenging especially when the
burst gaps are small and we are working
on in finding improved codes for these I
should mention we have also looked at
the network streaming problem where we
have found rank distance counter parts
of this course
instead of MDS convolutional codes we
are looking at records with rank
distance in the convolutional setup it
will be interesting to look at systems
theoretic approach so looking at dual
quotes for my des for example
understanding this trade-off small from
a fundamental Systems Theory point of
view and also looking at the
probabilistic channels directly instead
of doing the deterministic approximation
and finding course maybe there are good
lower bounds on the loss probability
directly for the Gilbert Iliad Channel
and that can be used to compare our
achievability results so I think I'll
stop here
so my intuition is that this the reason
why we need two layers is not so much to
do with the channel it is like you know
we have the repetition code and the
racial code the racial code deals more
with coding across packets right and so
we have to do simultaneous recovery the
repetition code is like intra packet
coding you just take the packet and you
repeat it so it has a nice sequential
part to it but it does not allow coding
across packet so it is not robust and so
when we combine the two we are balancing
the trade-off between inter packet
coding and intra packet coding and that
is what why we needed to split it into
two sub packets and then find the right
trade-off of how much in each layer to
allocate right I am NOT so we have to
design codes with like say burst and
isolated losses and many other variants
and often it turns out we have to divide
it into two groups like this and then
find the right number of layers to add
like in terms of parity checks to deal
with different arranger patterns so but
in terms of source splitting we haven't
really found examples where you go
beyond two layers but that's a great
question but there there were a lot of
old bounds on combined burst and random
error correction right there any of
those or any of those similar to the
kind of bounds you got here I mean you
could correct bursts of size B and a
certain number of random errors within
some you know or with some guard space
or something like that right defined and
you're you're lucky now over a window
but it seems like some of the parameters
are the same and maybe some of the
bounds might be similar yeah it's
possible to be honest I'm not too
familiar with all the literature exactly
right that if there is a sort of a
window like if the boss happens
repeatedly it in a sense defines the
decoding delay you cannot go beyond that
and then so I don't think those bounds
would apply directly because they didn't
have its delay constraint like you there
might be some so I think even looking at
errors is interesting I was only
focusing on the ratios and I do believe
that is the counterpart to errors